hi Emily and some of its ease today and
I love the film
oh good mazing good thank you and so
rachel is very hard on herself and she
drinked really heavily and she's
disrupted by nature yeah and the matting
that was a really exhausting role to
play it was exhausting and exciting sort
of a mixture of being challenging and
exhausting at the same time and so I
think um you know for me I'm always
looking for opportunities that can
stretch me so she's a very destructive
unreliable narrator for this and how I
did you switch off at me you know at the
end of the day where did you go I have a
long car ride home which is usually it's
a good way to prepare in the morning a
good way to slow it down at night how
did you celebrate when you got the call
or when far though um I don't know I
mean I I um I can't remember - yeah I
remember I was really excited I mean I
think that I had seen everybody reading
this book I had not read it at the time
um and then when I read it I just
thought how amazing to have a blackout
drunk be your protagonist and three
really fantastic roles for women in a
mainstream film is very unusual and you
got to film scenes with Lisa Kudrow
which is exciting and were your friends
fan and please the enormous friends
phone and play tell me there was a
smelly cat duet no I wouldn't do that to
her that could have been so great and so
you've obviously just been cast in
another iconic literally role and also
met with universal joy how intimidated
are you about stepping into Julie
Andrews shoes and picking up her half
hit bag Oh
I mean intimidated and excited it's
quite a heart-racing project and really
beautiful script and it was all new
music so new songs so I think that I
hope that I can just establish a
different Mary Poppins for this
generation but because I don't think you
can ever try and outshine what Julie did
and it was so wonderful and so nostalgic
for people to think about the original
Mary Poppins so we'll just have to be my
take on it again and lastly and here is
you like to be an Lee's stuck in a train
carriage with I'm who's you like to be
different
hmm least like to be stuck in a cold I'm
gonna get myself today um I always get
myself into trouble I was about to say
someone but I think I won't how about
them knows he was denied most uh I I
would most like to be stuck on a train
with see this is gonna make people
roller eyes but with my family yeah
that's right that's really nice that's
really love it and I'm someone's of the
film thank you so much for watching
please thank you
you